all right what's going on guys um man
here in Colorado I just got done eating
subway and I get these weird ideas from
time to time like a topic will just crop
up to me like an ideal will pop up to me
and I usually try to wait until I get
home
to record in on you know my microphone
and have my editor make a video out of
it or something like that but this time
I thought it'd be kind of fun to do like
a little vlog format sort of thing and I
want to talk about the Fantastic Four
being in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
here's a reason why so it was a big to
do with the idea of the the Fantastic
Four being in there and we knew just by
virtue of literature we knew just by
virtue of rumors and things like that
that like some new characters are going
to be introduced there was that
interview that Scarlett Johansson been
where she talked about how there is a
fight scene in I think it's the ending
Infinity Gauntlet is the second is the
name of the second infinity war movie
but she talked about how there's going
to be this massive battle with like
daños and 60 some-odd superheroes so
there's going to be something like 40 or
50 new superheroes that we haven't seen
before they're going to be introduced at
infinity war well then time progressed
rumors began to expand rumors began to
grow and you know turn one thing to
another and then like rumors about a
group called the Black Order started
coming out now here's the deal the black
order was a group that was introduced by
Jonathan Hickman during Avengers and New
Avengers and the black order was
basically just Corvus glaive and Proxima
midnight and ebony maw and so pretty
awesome characters but we didn't really
know anything about them they were just
kind of ambiguous Proxima midnight was
probably one of the most interesting
there was also Black Swan she was really
cool as well and so the question was you
know are they going to be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe well the idea of the
Black Order is that they were so
ambiguous and they only really served a
purpose I'm kind of being like two
lieutenants of Thanos that was really a
time it was idea you know that like
Corvus glaive for example would show up
on a planet and basically say hey look
Stannis wants like all the firstborn on
this planet and like he wants them all
killed because it's really weird because
Dan'l's was trying to track down his kid
and kill all we're trying to yeah trying
to kill his offspring it was kind of
crazy it led to
battle god it led to this amazing moment
in infinity I think it was and Santos
invades earth right because it's like
word is reached in tears that there is a
child there's a watch it really a
teenager like a young adult that lives
in the inhuman city of Attilan that
looks like Thanos even has like the
weird chin and everything and so that
house goes there can he encounters black
bolt of the Inhumans and he's like we
can do this easy or we can do it hard
like you can give me what I want and I
will go away or I will destroy
everything you love
now black bolt like his voice is strong
enough to like shatter planets so it
leads to a conflict between them and
that also is like tell me where my son
is a black bolt just screams no and so
so the adults grab to do so badass
sandals grab he's like fine keep your
secrets carry them with you to the grab
you like smashes it facedown on the
ground it's one of the good it's one of
the coolest things ever it's amazing
this amazing candle I need to cover
infinity we'll do that once we get to
like infinity war and we start going
going back through all of Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers one like Black
Panther reforms the Illuminati and like
Captain America gets the Infinity
Gauntlet and like the Infinity stones
explode and the time stone vanishes it
gets crazy
like it gets absolutely nuts but
nonetheless so yeah the black order was
just was really ambiguous group well I
will sit here in subway and I was eating
lunch you know I was eating fresh and I
was like all right right now at d23
which is the comic book adventure now
we're going to give comic convention but
the expo that Disney puts on every two
years um right now at d23 they unveiled
Thanos this huge life modeling a
life-size model of Thanos which is
insane how awesome it looks you can see
pictures of it I posted a picture on
Twitter you can see pictures of it
online but there's four other statues
hidden behind them and they're all just
kind of covered like they're cloaked
supposedly today they're supposed to be
revealing and I have no idea what going
to work on but I was sitting there
thinking I was like I mean one of those
statues is bigger than the others and it
could be several things it could be like
dwarf I think it was black dwarf it
could be you know Corvus glaive with a
staff it could be you know Proxima
with her staff it could be evany modulo
making any number of different
characters from the black order but then
I started thinking and I was like but
like fox though so here's the deal
fox did not have the ability to make
that legion TV show of their own accord
the only only ability to make movies or
make sure the only only ability to make
movies about comfor characters not TV
shows that's the reason why you never
saw a you know sony animated television
show or animated movie like a sony
produced animated spider-man movie until
the deal was struck with Marvel and now
there is a Sony animated movie about
Myles where else Sony didn't have the
rights to do that they could only use
the characters in film form that's why
there was never like a Sony Spiderman TV
show or that's why there was never an
x-men TV show but now with this deal
that's been struck I mean there's like
you know Marvel supposedly struck a deal
with Fox and so they can do like New
Mutants TV show and just different
things like that
but the question is what does Marvel get
out of it you know it's like spider-man
for example you know I mean we're going
to sidetrack all over the place but it's
like spider-man right like Marvel didn't
need spider-man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it was cool to have it but he
was not needed by any standard of
measurement and so I think that Marvel
worked out a deal where they got to use
spider-man and infinity war both movies
and Civil War and then they make money
off that spider-man gets a homecoming
movie homecoming parts 1 & 2 and Sony
gets gets all the money off that and
then I think what's going to happen is
an infinity war or homecoming -
whichever one comes last Peter Parker is
going to die and I think Miles Morales
is going to take his place
I think Marvel got Miles Morales for the
MCU and Sony keeps Peter Parker I feel
like that's what happened I love it's
true I'm just kind of speculating just
doing it out there but I feel like
that's what happened now that brings us
back around the Fantastic Four
I would like to believe that the black
order and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is not a beanie ma or Corvus glaive or
Proxima midnight or any of those
characters black dwarf I'd like to
believe that like order
Ingram de thing and Reed Richards and
Susan storm and Johnny Storm and here's
the reason why in marble comics it all
really kind of comes down to like Drax
the destroyer director destroyers also
as he is you know and as he's played by
the T says all through the years in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe unless they
flesh his backstory out even further
they're probably not going to go with
the comic book origin and the comic
books um I can't talk in the comic books
Drax the destroyer was a human named
Arthur Douglas and eventually his family
was basically killed when Thanos invaded
the earth looking for a cosmic universe
some like that anyway I remember if
Arthur Douglas died or not I feel like
he did and then the spirit was
resurrected and he was turned into Drax
the destroyer by Chronos the god of
Saturn's eternals cosmic entity the god
of Thanos was raised basically uh which
initially led to Drax the destroyer
having the ability to be able to track
down Stannis anywhere in the universe no
matter where he is now I would like to
believe that with Peter quill out there
we already know that there's humans out
in space we know Peter Quill's not the
only one I mean you guys would go back
and read guardians together watch
guardians of the galaxy you'll see other
human beings like I mean not very many
but you'll see like one or two other
human beings around you know and like
know we're in different places like that
so we know that there are other people
out there but we don't know how they got
there we just were there but the idea to
me is I'd like to believe that at some
point along the line something happened
either the Fantastic Four were like
exploring space or they were out doing
their own thing whatever the case may
have been Stannis got a hold of them and
like corrupted them or force them into
servitude or something along those lines
I have no idea but they are officially
indoctrinated by FanDuel they're serving
as his lieutenants as his Black Order
infinity war happens maybe tano's
already has the mine stone wouldn't even
have a vision still have um infinity war
happens Santos is defeated the Fantastic
Four not really vanish before but like
read Susan Ben and Johnny are freed from
the control of Thanos and the Avengers
are like come back with us
and they go to earth and they start
calling themselves the Fantastic Four
that's what I would like to believe I
have no evidence for that I have no
evidence to make that case no evidence
to say that it's true but I think it
would be awesome I think it'd be pretty
stellar the Fantastic Four in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe would be a huge deal
here's reason why the Fantastic Four the
first family of Marvel Comics I mean
it's they are the superhero team that
said everything else in motion for
Marvel's popularity I mean the Fantastic
Four all the reason we're really one of
the reasons why Marvel succeeded in the
first place so the Fantastic Four not
succeeded we probably wouldn't have
gotten spider-man or Thor or Captain
America's return or Iron Man or you know
Incredible Hulk or Avengers or any of
those because the Fantastic Four were
the ones that made Marvel popular it was
their answer to DC's Justice League of
America and so I'd like to believe that
with the Fantastic Four being so
significant the legacy they could form
and the kind of stories they could tell
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe would
be huge
now something else to also keep in mind
and the other reason why I also want
this to be true is because if the Marvel
Cinematic Universe got the Fantastic
Four and they're not calling them the
Fantastic Four when they got read Ben
Johnny and Sue then most likely it also
means that they got Galactus and the
Silver Surfer and Doctor Doom I feel
like infinity war wouldn't be infinity
war without the Silver Surfer and
Galactus it just falls short interest
doesn't work I don't anyway guys let me
know down in the comments section what
you guys think I mean I'd like to
believe that it's true let me know what
you guys think I like these little blog
style videos we're just kind of talk to
you guys for a few minutes about stuff
but let me know what you guys think and
yeah I will catch you all later please